je suis en train de contener les moules
c'est pour après mettre du chocolat
dedans et faire des sapins Gladis Marie
a entamé il y a quelques mois une
formation de chocolatière à 18 ans elle
a opté pour l'apprentissage ici si
j'aurais pas l'école j'aurais je serais
tout le temps ici et je serai coupé de
tout le monde quoi et c'est vrai qu'il y
a des avantages à l'école quand on a le
weekend mais de l'autre côté je préfère
être ici parce qu'on apprend plus de
choses à l'école elle apprend la
fabrication de ganaches et praliné et
comment faire des glaçages et moulag
technique qu'elle pefine ensuite à
l'atelier passionné par le travail du
chocolat la première fois que ce métier
m'a donné envie c'était quand j'étais
aller à une journée porte ouverte dans
un CFA et j'avais vu des pièces
commerciales en chocolat et puis c'est
côté artisti qui m'a attiré et bah par
la suite j'aime bien aussi c'est
minutieux
c'est c'est bon aussi pour l'encadrer un
maître d'apprentissage qui doit avoir
acquis au moins 5 ans d'expérience et
bien évidemment le chef d'atelier qui
supervise son évolution
elle travaille très très bien elle a
fait le salon du chocolat avec nous je
pense qu'elle est heureuse ouais ouais
ça se passe très bien il y a de plus en
plus de filles c'est bien de travailler
avec les filles elles sont plus
munieuses l'atelier de Franck Dobos
compte quatre apprentis deux en
patisserie et deux en chocolaterie un
parcours que le chef a lui-même emprunté
à ses débuts de mon temps quand on
partait en apprentissage c'était plutôt
la voie de garage ceux qui travaillent
pas bien à l'école il partient à
l'apprentissage et aujourd'hui moins
c'est c'est quand même plus valorisé
dans les Yvelines 42 CFA forment plus de
16000 apprentis un statut de plus en
plus prisé par les 1625 ans